[Music]
cafe cafe is kansas city's first
vietnamese coffee shop
so it is essentially a coffee shop on
wheels and we specialize in amplifying
the asian narrative
by
including all flavor profiles of
vietnamese coffee and all of our coffee
beans are from vietnam
so before the pandemic i spent 10 years
in new york being an actor i studied
musical theater in college and i did a
lot of touring productions of various
broadway shows and most recently right
before the pandemic i was on the
broadway revival tour of miss saigon
while i was on the road with miss saigon
i had taken a trip to vietnam during one
of our breaks
and it really inspired me to be
a little bit more involved in my
community and in my culture so i'm a
first generation
vietnamese american i'm the first one in
my family to be born here so when i took
the trip to vietnam it really resonated
with me that
there were a lot of things about my
culture and a lot of things about myself
that felt untapped and while i was on
the road i kept thinking i want to do
something for my community i want to do
something that
is more than a line on a resume
essentially and i got the idea of
starting a coffee shop because the
coffee culture in vietnam is just like
incredible it's super dope but i didn't
plan on doing it this soon
the pandemic hit
and we were out of a job so our show
stopped completely we were out of work
and then our show got cancelled like for
real so
i didn't have a job to go back to
and at the time i was living out of a
suitcase for like almost 18 months miss
saigon had come to kansas city for two
weeks and while we were here
we were just
enamored by the city and i thought wow
this would be really cool to start my
coffee shop here you know so because of
the pandemic i didn't have anywhere to
go so
we came here and i said you know what
i'm gonna jump and let's just do it
it is a mobile coffee shop right now
because during the pandemic i wasn't
able to receive a loan or any funding
because everything was being shut down
so much i took every penny that i had
from savings which was like 10 grand and
then i also did a kickstarter where i
asked the community of kansas city to
essentially help me
and that's all i started with that and i
just
did everything myself i still do a lot
myself like 95 of it myself including
like social media photos all the pop-ups
all of the labor up until last month was
all me
we started off you know sales were like
really low because i was just doing a
small lemonade stand
you know essentially i was just setting
up a table having some vietnamese
lemonade and vietnamese coffee at a
table and like serving it that way just
to get my name out there
when i first saw my balance sheet and i
realizing we were really
making a lot of money
it was almost a shock because
i'm not used to big figures like that
and
the
the speed of which we got there i mean
i'm just talking like within a month we
doubled and then in a month we tripled
so that was
crazy to be like oh my god
uh not only is this
becoming popular on social media but on
paper and like the numbers
it was actually becoming lucrative you
know i could actually make a living i
could pay my employees you know it was a
shock and it was also
legit
at first building our business
was difficult financially because of the
pandemic
then it became difficult because we were
so loud and we were so outspoken about
being asian
and
we felt like the the temperature of the
country was just
really unbearable because of all of the
attacks
but what we found was that because we
continue to be strong in our opinions
and we continued to fight for you know
the asian community in town we found
that the community itself
was so much more supportive than we
could ever imagine
we threw a stop asian hate vigil for
kansas city where over 500 people showed
up and we taught everyone how to light
incense so we did an incense tribute
instead of a candlelit
vigil and that was just so magical and
so amazing because we saw kansas city
come out they were like yeah we we want
to be there for you we want to show you
that you're safe here and that
we don't want anyone to attack you
either
we've felt targeted a few times and so
we've like closed down our shop to give
ourselves just like some space
to feel safe
but as a result of our vigil kansas city
and the mayor of kansas city declared
may to officially be aapi heritage month
in the city of kansas city and we as a
coffee shop were able to speak with the
mayor that day we got like an official
decree it was awesome and so
i feel like
there's been good and bad with
this shop but overall
it's just been
better for us and
we've helped the community recognize
that hey there is a community here and
it deserves
to have a platform as well
being an asian woman and
having a brand and a company
where being asian is at the forefront
of our brand and of our company that's
been so rewarding because i've gotten
hundreds of dms and messages and emails
from other asian people
thanking me for doing this
and i
i knew that there needed to be
more things and more businesses that
made being asian super cool
and i've tried really hard to build this
brand to make other asian kids out there
be like
that's cool and i feel cool and i feel
seen and i feel heard
that that's probably been like the most
rewarding because we've created the
space for that reason we wanted to
amplify the narrative within the midwest
where
asians aren't as heard or recognized and
feel more invisible in these areas of
the country and
being able to kind of
look at my shop and be like
i did that like that's
that's really cool
you